استخدم فريقك نماذج لما نعرفه الآن
عن co19 إلى جانب فيروسات
أخرى لإنشاء سيناريوهات محتملة
للوباء الذي خلص إلى وجود
حاجة محتملة للتباعد الاجتماعي حتى عام 2022 ،
هل يمكنك شرح كيف وجدت ذلك
تمامًا ، لذلك هناك
طريقتان للوباء  في إحداها ، نقضي
على الفيروس ، أعتقد أنه مع الانتشار
العالمي للفيروس ، من غير المحتمل تمامًا
في نهاية الوباء الثاني لأن
هناك مناعة كافية في
السكان ، لذلك
كنا مهتمين في الخلفية بالسؤال عن
تأثير التباعد الاجتماعي و  ماذا
يحدث عندما نوقف جهدًا لمرة واحدة ،
لذا فإننا نقوم بالمباعدة
الاجتماعية بفكرة تسطيح المنحنى
ومحاولة منع إغراق
البنية التحتية للرعاية الصحية لدينا ، لذلك إذا
نجحنا في القيام بذلك ، فإننا أيضًا نجعل
الكثير من الأشخاص عرضة لـ
العدوى بحيث إذا توقفنا عن
التباعد الاجتماعي بعد أربعة أسابيع ثمانية أسابيع
أو 12 أسبوعًا أو ماذا لديك -
فسيظل هناك مجموعة من الأشخاص الذين
نحن معرضون للإصابة وقد نرى
وصول العدوى مرة أخرى مما قد
يدفعنا إلى إعادة التباعد الاجتماعي ، لذا ضع
في اعتبارك أن هدفنا هو
الوصول إلى مستوى مناعة السكان في
حالة عدم وجود لقاح أو
أنواع أخرى من التدخلات المحتملة ، ما
قد نراه هو هذا  نوع من تشغيل / إيقاف
التباعد المتقطع وللحصول على
مناعة السكان مرة أخرى ستستغرق هذه النقطة النهائية
حتى عام 2022 وهذا
مبني على الاعتقاد بأنه بمجرد
إصابتك بالعدوى
ستطور مناعة هو هذا صحيح لأنني
أعني أنني أعرف أن ذلك لم يحدث.  لقد ثبت بشكل
قاطع أن هذا صحيح ،
نحن في هذا النموذج على افتراض أن
العدوى تجلب معها
حماية مناعية كافية لتستمر على
الأقل في تلك المدة ، لذا فإن فكرة عام
2022 هي بالضبط ما أعنيه أنك حصلت على هذا
التاريخ حقًا
فقط من خلال الإسقاط  عندما
يطور عدد كافٍ من الناس ما يسمونه مناعة القطيع ،
فهذا صحيح ، لذا فإن ما
اتخذناه كنهج لهذا هو
الأخذ في الاعتبار  نحن نقوم
بتسوية المنحنى لمحاولة تقليل الضغط
على البنية التحتية للرعاية الصحية وأن
ما نريد القيام به هو وضع
تدابير التباعد الاجتماعي هذه عندما
يبدو أننا عندما نتوقع أننا سنبدأ
في الاقتراب من البنية التحتية للرعاية الحرجة
من هذا النوع  من
الحد الأقصى هناك ومن ثم يمكننا
إيقاف تشغيله لأننا بدأنا نرى
المنحنى ينخفض مرة أخرى لدينا هذا النوع من نم
ذج منظم الحرارة حيث نع
ير لمحاولة الحفاظ على البنية التحتية للرعاية الصحية مرة أخرى عن
ما نستخدم ذل
هدفنا هو وضع تصور لهذه
الجولات المتعددة من التباعد الاجتماعي
الذي يأخذنا إلى عام 2022